This is 99% infasible. I'm Roman Mars. For a lot of people being a professional baseball player sounds like a total dream job. I mean, you get paid millions of dollars to play a game, but there are downsides. Like if you have a bad night at work as a baseball player, it's usually in front of 40,000 screaming fans. This story is about one of those nights in Houston, Texas. The Toronto Blue Jays were losing to the hometown Astros when they called in pitcher Mike Bulsinger. That's baseball reporter Ben Rider. He covered the game for 15 years as a rider at Sports Illustrated. Some major league baseball players have job security and 20 million
这几乎是不可能的。我是罗曼·马尔斯。对很多人来说，成为一名职业棒球运动员听起来就像是一份绝佳的梦想工作。我的意思是，你通过玩游戏就能赚到几百万美元，但也有不好的地方。比如，如果你作为一个棒球运动员在工作当晚表现糟糕，通常是在四万名尖叫的球迷面前。这个故事讲的是在德克萨斯州休斯顿发生的这样一个夜晚。多伦多蓝鸟队在落后于主场作战的休斯顿太空人队时，换上了投手迈克·鲍尔辛格。那是棒球记者本·赖德。他作为《体育画报》的撰稿人报道了这场比赛15年。一些美国职业棒球大联盟的球员拥有工作保障和2000万
dollar salaries. They're paid huge bonuses just for getting drafted and their teams of spent years developing them. Then there are guys like Bolesinger. I signed for a thousand dollars with a billion dollar organization so a thousand dollars. I think it was six hundred and sixty seven dollars after taxes. They don't have $667 after taxes. They don't have that much invested in you. He make jokes about it. It's like a bucket of baseball for them. The night both of them came in, he was facing a stacked Astros lineup.
美元的薪水。他们仅仅因为被选中就能拿到巨额奖金，他们的球队花了多年时间培养他们。然后还有像鲍尔辛格这样的人。我以一千美元的价格签约加入一个拥有十亿美元资产的组织，所以是一千美元。我想扣税后是六百六十七美元。他们扣税后没有667美元。他们在你身上没有投入那么多。他对此开玩笑说。对他们来说这就像是一桶棒球。他们两个上场的那个晚上，他面对的是一个实力雄厚的太空人队打线。
It's star players like Alex Brugman and Carlos Beltran. They were a total juggernaut. Oh yeah. I mean, they were unbelievable. From what you see, they're runs there putting up in my head. I was like, this is the best team of baseball. Bulsinger came into the game with a man on first in two outs. All he had to do was get one more out and the Indian was over. Just get one out. I mean, in theory, it should be easy. But instead, Bulsinger walked his first batter. The second hit a three run homer. Then the
那是像亚历克斯·布雷格曼和卡洛斯·贝尔特兰这样的明星球员。他们简直势不可挡。哦，是的。我的意思是，他们太不可思议了。从你看到的来看，他们在我的脑海里不断得分。当时我想，这是棒球界最强的球队。鲍尔辛格上场时，场上有一名一垒跑垒员，还有两个出局。他要做的就是再拿下最后一个出局数，这一局就结束了。只要拿下一个出局数。我的意思是，理论上这应该很简单。但相反，鲍尔辛格保送了他的第一个击球手。第二个击球手击出了一记三分本垒打。然后
Astros really started pouring it on. There's belt shunts on the first pitch. They're just kept getting hits, laying off pitches. I'm trying to remember a time I was rocked more than that and I just don't remember a time Mike Bolsinger was stressed. He was a journeyman one bad outing could be the difference between hanging on to his job or being sent down to the Minor leagues his major league career hung in the balance every single time he took the mound his major league career hung in the balance every single time he took the mound. The eighth batter he faced was Alex Breggman. With the bases loaded, Bulsinger was desperate not to give up another home run. So he turned to his best pitch, his slow looping curve ball. But Breggman was ready for it and he hit it deep.
太空人队真的开始大开杀戒了。贝尔特兰在第一球就击中了。他们不断安打，放过好球。我努力回想我曾经受过比这更惨重打击的时候，却怎么也想不起来迈克·鲍尔辛格曾感到压力。他是一名四处征战的流浪球员，一次糟糕的表现可能就是保住工作还是被下放到小联盟的区别。他每一次踏上投手丘，他的大联盟生涯都悬于一线。他每一次踏上投手丘，他的大联盟生涯都悬于一线。他面对的第八个击球手是亚历克斯·布雷格曼。在满垒的情况下，鲍尔辛格拼命不想再失掉本垒打。于是他转向他最拿手的球，他那缓慢下坠的弧线球。但布雷格曼已经做好了准备，将其击得很远。
At that point I was like, well, what else is new? Everyone else is hitting everything off me and my eyes will just go over the fence. The ball kept going and going and going. And actually, the blue chase caught it. Bulsinger got his one out, and the inning was finally over. It had gone just about as badly as an inning can possibly go.
当时我想，好吧，还有什么新鲜的？所有其他人都把我的球全击出去了，我眼睁睁看着球飞过围墙。球一直在飞，一直在飞，一直在飞。事实上，蓝鸟队接住了。鲍尔辛格拿到了他的一个出局数，这一局终于结束了。这一局的发展可以说是糟糕透顶了。
Mike Bulsinger gave up four runs on four hits and three walks. He was stunned by what happened. He felt good that day. He was throwing good pitches. But the Astros just kept hitting them. I remember in the interview after the game, I told the reporter, I was like, man, it's just like, it was like they knew it I was throwing. Like, they were all over my stuff.
迈克·鲍尔辛格因4支安打和3次保送失了4分。他对发生的事情感到震惊。他那天感觉很好。他投出了好球。但太空人队就是不断把它们打出去。我记得赛后采访时，我对记者说，天哪，这就像，就像他们知道我要投什么一样。就像，他们完全看穿了我的球路。
There's nothing I could do. Mike Walsinger was demoted to the minor leagues that night, like right after the game was over, and he stayed in the minor leagues. After 2017, he played a few seasons in Japan, but he would never pitch in the big leagues again. Bolesinger had a lot of time to replay that final inning in his head. He thought he'd thrown the ball well against the Astros. His arm felt good, his velocity was normal, his curve ball was biting.
我对此无能为力。迈克·鲍尔辛格那天晚上被降级到小联盟，就在比赛结束后不久，并且他留在了小联盟。2017年之后，他在日本打了几个赛季，但再也没有在大联盟投过球。鲍尔辛格有很多时间在脑海中重播最后一局。他认为自己对阵太空人队时球投得很好。他的手臂感觉很好，球速正常，他的弧线球很有威力。
It just hadn't mattered. It turns out there was a reason the Houston Astros hitters seemed like they knew exactly what pitches Btsinger was going to throw, and that's because they did, and they knew because the Astros were engaged in an age-old practice called sign stealing. They were cheating. Baseball is a game with a ton of nonverbal communication between players and coaches, all of which happens out in the open. Coaches will swipe their hands across their chest and down their legs to tell a player to steal a base or lay off a pitch.
但这根本没用。事实证明，休斯顿太空人队的击球手似乎确切知道鲍尔辛格要投什么球是有原因的，那是因为他们确实知道，他们知道是因为太空人队在进行一项古老的 pratiques（实践）叫做偷暗号。他们在作弊。棒球是一项在球员和教练之间有着大量非语言沟通的运动，所有这些都在光天化日之下进行。教练会把手从胸前滑过，顺着腿滑下来，告诉球员盗垒或放弃击球。
Infielders will wavid each other to move over a couple of feet to the left or to the right. There are thousands of moments like this in every game. And the most important nonverbal communication is between the pitcher and the catcher. The catcher is responsible for knowing the opposing hitters' strengths and weaknesses and for suggesting what pitches to throw. He does it using a system of discrete hand signals. If you've seen a baseball game, you've seen this happen. The catcher crouches down, he puts one hand between the shin guards, and he starts pointing
内野手会挥手让彼此向左或向右移动几英尺。每场比赛中都有成千上万这样的时刻。而最重要的非语言沟通发生在投手和捕手之间。捕手负责了解对方击球手的长处和短处，并建议投什么球。他使用一套离散的手势系统来做到这一点。如果你看过棒球比赛，你一定见过这种情况。捕手蹲下来，把一只手放在护腿板之间，然后开始指向
his fingers towards the dirt. One finger means throw a fastball, two is a curveball. Teams will mix up their signs like when a runner is on second who has a clear view of the catcher, but for the most part, this is just how it's done. If a batter knows what pitch is coming, it's a lot easier to get on base, because that knowledge means they can figure out exactly when to swing or let a pitch go. Here's Mike Bulsinger. I think the hardest thing at doom in any sport
他的手指朝向泥地。一根手指意味着投直球，两根是弧线球。球队会打乱他们的暗号，比如当二垒上有跑垒员时，他对捕手有一览无余的视野，但就大部分而言，事情就是这样完成的。如果击球手知道什么球要来，上垒就会容易得多，因为这种了解意味着他们可以准确算出何时挥棒或放过一球。这是迈克·鲍尔辛格。我认为在任何运动中最难的事情
is to hit a baseball. So a pitcher already has an advantage right there. But a hit or not knowing what you're going to throw, or where you're going to throw it, I mean, it's almost like hitting, unless you're extremely good at it, it's a guessing game. This is where sign Stealing comes in. If you can decode an opposing picture of Signs, you have a big competitive advantage.
就是击打棒球。所以投手在那一点上已经占据了优势。但击球手不知道你要投什么，或者你要把球投到哪里，我的意思是，这几乎就像击球一样，除非你在这方面极其擅长，否则这就是一场猜谜游戏。这就是偷暗号发挥作用的地方。如果你能破解对方投手的暗号，你就在竞争中占据了巨大优势。
Sign Stealing is a two-step process. First, someone has to see the capture signals, and then they have to communicate that information to the batter, and this whole process has to take place in a matter of seconds. This may sound like a lot of effort, but as long as there have been nonverbal signs in baseball, crafty players have been stealing them. In the early days of baseball, sign stealing was almost like a game within the game. Teams and players would try all kinds of tricks to get a glimpse of what the catcher was signaling to the pitcher.
偷暗号是一个两步的过程。首先，有人必须看到捕手的暗号，然后他们必须将该信息传达给击球手，整个过程必须在几秒钟内完成。这听起来可能需要付出很多努力，但只要棒球运动中存在非语言暗号，狡猾的球员就会去偷取它们。在棒球的早期，偷暗号几乎就像是比赛中的一场游戏。球队和球员会尝试各种各样的把戏来窥探捕手给投手的暗号。
If the axiom, which I heard many times, you're not stealing, you're not trying. That's Paul Dixon, the author of the Hidden Language of Baseball. He says the picture. That's Paul Dixon, the author of the Hidden Language of Baseball. He says the first recorded instance of sign stealing goes all the way back to 1876, the very first year of the National League. The shack was hidden away from fans almost like a hunting blind. hanging from a telegraph bowl, overlooking the stadium in Hartford. The shack was hidden away from fans almost like a hunting blind. Details are sketchy because this happened in 1876, but apparently there was a man hiding in the shack, probably with a pair of binoculars.
如果那句我听过很多次的名言所说：“不偷，就是没在努力。”那是保尔·迪克森，《棒球隐秘语言》的作者。他说那个棚子。那是保尔·迪克森，《棒球隐秘语言》的作者。他说有记录的第一次偷暗号要追溯到1876年，那是国家联盟的头一年。那个棚子隐藏在球迷的视线之外，几乎就像一个狩猎盲。悬挂在一个电线杆上，俯瞰着哈特福德的体育场。那个棚子隐藏在球迷的视线之外，几乎就像一个狩猎盲。细节很模糊，因为这发生在1876年，但显然有一个人躲在棚子里，可能拿着一幅双筒望远镜。
And they were stealing the signs from there and giving them somehow down to the guys on the field and they were taking it from there. In those early days, Signed Stealing wasn't against the rules of baseball. There was no clear line that teams knew not to cross. Lots of people considered it cheating. But much like, you know, in Airbud, there was nothing in the rule book that outlawed a dog from playing basketball. Nothing in the rule book stopped players from building a shack on a telegraph pole
他们从那里偷看暗号，然后某种方式传达给场上的人，他们就从那里接手。在早期，偷暗号并不违反棒球规则。没有一条球队都知道不能跨越的清晰界限。很多人认为这是作弊。但很像，你知道的，在《神犬也疯狂》里，规则书里没有任何条款禁止狗打篮球。规则书里没有什么能阻止球员在电线杆上搭建一个棚子
and spying on the other teams with binoculars. The sign stealing arms race may have had some big impacts on the game. Catchers in baseball used to lean over to receive pitches, but that made it too easy for other teams to steal their signs. So it's believed that that's why catchers began to squat. There have also been some more outlandish and creative efforts. Like in 1900, there was an incident during a game between the Cincinnati Reds and the Philadelphia Phillies.
并用双筒望远镜监视对方球队。偷暗号的军备竞赛可能对比赛产生了重大影响。棒球里的捕手过去常常弯下身子接球，但这使得其他球队太容易偷他们的暗号了。所以人们认为这就是为什么捕手开始蹲着。还有一些更加离奇和有创意的努力。比如在1900年，辛辛那提红人队和费城费城人队的一场比赛中发生了一起事件。
The red shortstop Tommy Corcoran noticed the Phillies third base coach was always putting his foot in a specific patch of dirt on the field just before a pitch was coming in. And Corcoran thought something's wrong here. He goes tearing across the field and starts kicking with his foot, digging up the dirt and dirt is flying everywhere. And he comes with his little box. And in the box is a buzzer. Corcoran discovered that the Philly's coach had been stepping on the buzzer box. And the buzzer is taking a telegraphed signal and buzzing,
红人队的游击手汤米·科科兰注意到费城人队的三垒教练在投球到来之前总是把脚踩在球场上的一块特定泥土上。科科兰觉得这里面有问题。他冲过球场，开始用脚踢，铲起泥土，泥土到处飞扬。然后他发现了一个小盒子。盒子里是一个蜂鸣器。科科兰发现费城人队的教练一直在踩蜂鸣器盒。蜂鸣器接收电报信号并发出蜂鸣声，
but it's not loud enough to be heard, but you could feel it at the bottom of this foot. It turned out that Philly's coach was receiving a modified Morse code to tell him what pitch was coming. The message was coming from a Philly's player who is using binoculars to look through a people in the outfield fence to watch the other team's signs. The player relayed those signs to the coach using the buzzer, and then the coach sent
但声音不够大，听不见，但你能在脚底感受到它。事实证明，费城人队的教练正在接收经过修改的摩斯密码，以告诉他什么球要来。这个消息来自一个费城人队的球员，他用双筒望远镜透过外野栅栏上的一个小孔来观察对方球队的暗号。那个球员用蜂鸣器把这些暗号转达给教练，然后教练把
that message to the batter. Again, this might sound like way too much effort to steal signs, but every team was looking for even the smallest edge to win ball games. And it worked. Signed stealing probably helped the team win the World Series in 1948. Bob Veller, a Hall of Fame pitcher for the Cleveland team, used a telescope he brought back from World War II to pick up signs. They won the championship and Veller was pretty unrepentant about it.
那个信息发送给击球手。再次说明，这听起来可能为了偷暗号而付出了太多努力，但每支球队都在寻找哪怕最小的优势来赢得比赛。而且这起作用了。偷暗号可能帮助球队赢得了1948年的世界大赛。鲍勃·费勒，克利夫兰队的名人堂投手，用他从二战带回来的望远镜来获取暗号。他们赢得了冠军，而费勒对此毫无悔意。
Later he said, hey all-sphere and love and war and when you're trying to win a penit. And the 1948 World Series is all over. Signed stealing occupied a grey zone in baseball ethics. On one hand, players were hiding it from their opponents and from fans. On the other, everybody knew it was happening. One player, a Hall of Famer named Roger Swornesby, did an interview with True Magazine that was published under the headline, You Got to cheat to win in baseball. Because of this ethical gray area for years, it went like this.
后来他说，嘿，兵不厌诈，当你试图赢得锦标时。1948年的世界大赛已经结束。偷暗号在棒球道德中占据了一个灰色地带。一方面，球员们对对手和球迷隐瞒这一点。另一方面，每个人都知道它在发生。一名球员，一位名叫罗杰·斯旺斯比的名人堂成员，接受了《真实》杂志的采访，采访以“你在棒球中必须作弊才能赢”为标题发表。因为这个道德灰色地带，多年来情况一直是这样的。
A team would be caught sign stealing. The other team would say, hey, cut it out. And then they would come up with a new way of doing it. For years, Major League Baseball did nothing. But their view on sign stealing changed after a technological breakthrough in the 1950s. NBC had just invested in a camera with an 80-inch space master telephoto lens and unveiled it for a game of the week. The broadcasters realized that they could now clearly see the catcher's signs and told the audience what was coming before each pitch. One of the people who happened to watch the game that day was the commissioner who was
一支球队会被抓到偷暗号。另一支球队会说，嘿，别干了。然后他们会想出一种新的方法来做这件事。多年来，美国职业棒球大联盟什么也没做。但他们对偷暗号的看法在20世纪50年代的一次技术突破后发生了改变。美国国家广播公司刚刚投资了一台带有80英寸太空大师超长焦镜头的光学镜头，并在本周比赛中首次亮相。广播员们意识到他们现在可以清楚地看到捕手的暗号，并在每球投出之前告诉观众将要发生什么。那天碰巧看比赛的人之一是当时的专员，
forward-fric at the time and he thought it was a horrible idea. He immediately wanted NBC to agree not to use the camera again ever. If the guys in the booth could pick it up, the dugout could have the TV on. In 1962, the commissioner took a baby step to discourage sign stealing. Frick said publicly that he would overturn any game if it was proven the winning team had stolen signs using mechanical means, like a camera or a buzzer system, or even binoculars. This was the line in the sand in terms of baseball ethics. Players were allowed to steal with their eyes because that was considered a skill.
他当时非常生气，觉得这是一个糟糕的主意。他立刻希望美国国家广播公司同意再也不使用这个摄像机。如果转播席上的人能捕捉到它，休息区就可以开着电视。1962年，专员迈出了一小步，以阻止偷暗号。弗里克公开表示，如果有证据表明获胜球队通过机械手段（如摄像机、蜂鸣器系统甚至双筒望远镜）偷取了暗号，他将推翻任何比赛。这是棒球道德底线的一条沙地界限。球员被允许用眼睛去偷看，因为这被认为是一种技能。
But you couldn't steal signs using technology. Frick never actually punished anybody for sign stealing. And it took Major League Baseball 40 years to make an official rule about it. In 2000, they finally banned sign stealing by electronic means. They had to do it because technology was moving so quickly at that point. The 2000 rule was meant to stop cell phones from being used to steal signs. But by the early 2010s, baseball clubhouses were filled with video screens. Some of them were installed by the league itself when they started allowing teams to use
但你不能用技术手段偷暗号。弗里克实际上从未因为偷暗号惩罚过任何人。美国职业棒球大联盟花了40年时间才为此制定了一项正式规则。在2000年，他们终于禁止了电子手段偷暗号。他们不得不这么做，因为当时技术发展太快了。2000年的规则旨在阻止手机被用来偷暗号。但在2010年代初，棒球俱乐部会所里到处都是视频屏幕。其中一些是由联盟本身安装的，当时他们开始允许球队使用
video replay to challenge umpires' calls. The presence of all of these new screens made cheating incredibly tempting. Major League Baseball brought the snake into the garden of Eden, and then were surprised when the players took a bite of the apple. After a century of back and forth by the 2010s, there was finally a clear line in the rules of baseball. Sign stealing using technology was not okay. But with screens everywhere, it felt like a matter of time before someone crossed that
视频回放来挑战裁判的判决。所有这些新屏幕的存在使得作弊具有难以抗拒的诱惑力。美国职业棒球大联盟把蛇带进了伊甸园，然后当球员们咬了苹果时感到惊讶。经过一个世纪的拉锯战，到了2010年代，棒球规则中终于有了一条清晰的界限。利用技术手段偷暗号是不行的。但随着屏幕无处不在，感觉有人越过这条界限
line, and got caught doing it. Before there were winning games, and sending opposing pictures back to the minor leagues, the Houston Ashows were one of the worst teams in the history of baseball. Starting in 2011, they lost 100 games, 3 years in a row. Some of their games had local TV ratings of 0.0, which meant that Newlson couldn't confirm a single Houstonian who watched the games. They earned nicknames like The Last Rose and The Disast disastrous, which are pretty good. To turn things around, the Astros took a page from the Moneyball Playbook and hired a fleet of math nerds.
并在作弊时被抓到只是时间问题。在赢得比赛并将对方投手送回小联盟之前，休斯顿太空人队是棒球史上最差的球队之一。从2011年开始，他们连续3年输掉了100场比赛。他们的一些比赛当地电视收视率为0.0，这意味着尼尔森无法确认哪怕一个观看比赛的休斯顿人。他们赢得了诸如“最后的玫瑰”和“灾难”之类的绰号，这挺不错的。为了扭转局面，太空人队效仿了魔球手册，雇佣了一大批数学书呆子。
They worked on sophisticated algorithms that would help the Astros decide which players to draft and what strategies to execute on the field. The stats team was called the Nerd Cave. And so Ben, you know this because you actually covered the Astros first hand. Yeah, I did. So in 2014, I spent a lot of time in the team's front office for a story for Sports Illustrated. And when I got there, I found I was really impressed with what I saw. I came away convinced that they were on the path to turning things around.
他们致力于复杂的算法，这些算法将帮助太空人队决定挑选哪些球员以及在球场上执行什么策略。数据团队被称为“书呆子洞穴”。所以本，你知道这个，因为你亲自报道过太空人队。是的，我报道过。所以在2014年，我花了很多时间在球队的管理层，为《体育画报》写一篇报道。当我到达那里时，我发现我对所看到的印象深刻。我坚信他们正走在扭转局面的道路上。
So before the story ran, my editor asked me to estimate the year it's all going to come together. And I gave him my best guess. So at the end of 2014, the issue containing my piece hit mailboxes across the country with a cover that reads your 2017 World Series champs. Turns out I was right. In October 2017, Mike Bulsinger was sitting at a bar watching the Houston Astros play game 7 of the World Series. This was only three months after his final major league game. The Astros were playing one of Boastingers old teams, the L.A. Dodgers. The Dodgers, you know, I love every single one of them. It was the greatest organization I ever played for him. So I wanted them to win. But you felt the Astros deserved it.
所以在故事发表之前，我的编辑让我估计这一切将要结合在一起的年份。我给出了我最好的猜测。因此，在2014年底，包含我文章的那期杂志送达了全国各地的邮箱，封面写着“你们2017年世界大赛冠军”。事实证明我是对的。2017年10月，迈克·鲍尔辛格正坐在酒吧里观看休斯顿太空人队进行世界大赛第7场比赛。这距离他最后一场大联盟比赛仅仅三个月。太空人队正在对阵鲍尔辛格的老东家之一，洛杉矶道奇队。道奇队，你知道的，我爱其中的每一个人。这是我效力过的最伟大的组织。所以我希望他们赢。但你觉得太空人队实至名归。
Oh, what, I mean, yeah, 100%. I mean, I think to me, they had the better lineup. The Astros deserved it. Mike Bulsinger had mixed emotions about the whole series. He respected the Astros for their talent, and baseball fans everywhere were rooting for them. The Astros weren't just winners, they were likeable winners. They were playing in Houston's second world series ever, and they made it the same year Hurricane Harvey devastated their home city. Their stars like Jose Al-Tuva and Alex Bregman were fun to watch. It was a real Cinderella story. The sports illustrated cover in 2014, and the article by Ben Reader, they nailed
哦，什么，我的意思是，是的，100%。我的意思是，对我来说，他们有更好的打线。太空人队实至名归。迈克·鲍尔辛格对整个系列赛有着复杂的感情。他尊重太空人队的才华，世界各地的棒球迷都在为他们加油。太空人队不仅是赢家，他们是讨人喜欢的赢家。他们正在参加休斯顿历史上仅有的第二场世界大赛，而且他们进军世界大赛的同一年，飓风哈维毁了他们的家乡。他们的明星如何塞·阿尔图维和亚历克斯·布雷格曼看点十足。这是一个真正的灰姑娘故事。《体育画报》2014年的封面以及本·赖德的文章，他们完全说中了。
it. Hey, that's you. Yeah, although they kept pronouncing my name wrong. Anyhow, the Astros were champions. You have a line up like that. If you're hitting the ball like that, putting up numbers like that, there's no reason why you shouldn't win. You know, when you have good bitching, you're putting up 10 plus rounds of game.
嘿，那可是你。是的，尽管他们一直把我的名字念错。不管怎样，太空人队是冠军。你拥有这样一套打线。如果你像那样击球，打出那样的数字，你没有任何理由不赢。你知道，当你拥有出色的投球时，你一场比赛能得10分以上。
It feels like, how can you lose? Me, Mike Bulsinger, and almost everybody else assumed the Astros took the World Series because of their mix of young talent and the shrew decision making from the Nerd Cave. But two years later, we learned the truth. There was a lot more to the story. The Houston Astros cheated their way
感觉就像，怎么会输呢？我，迈克·鲍尔辛格，以及几乎所有人，都以为太空人队赢得世界大赛是因为他们年轻的天才组合和“书呆子洞穴”精明的决策。但两年后，我们知道了真相。故事远不止这些。休斯顿太空人队靠作弊赢得了
to a World Series championship in 2017. The publication, The Athlet 2017. In late 2019, a whistleblower came forward, a pitcher who had played with the Ashrows for three seasons. They have a guy on the record, a guy that was on the team. Mike Fires, a pitcher who laid out exactly what they do. Mike Fires alleged that the Ashrows sign-stealing during their championship season. Well the team had these fancy modern algorithms and an entire cave full of data nerds. Their sign-stealing plan was a lot like those used 50 years earlier.
2017年的世界大赛冠军。《The Athletic》杂志2017年。在2019年底，一名吹哨人站了出来，一个在太空人队效力了三个赛季的投手。他们有一个言之凿凿的人，一个在球队里的人。迈克·费尔斯，一个详细列出他们所作所行为的投手。迈克·费尔斯指控太空人队在他们的冠军赛季偷暗号。虽然这支球队拥有这些精美现代的算法和一整个满是数据书呆子的洞穴。他们的偷暗号计划很像50年前使用的那些。
It was a mix of high-tech tools and low-budget mischief. The Astros had a camera aimed directly at the other team's catcher, which broadcasts to a TV in the tunnel behind the dugout. To communicate the pitch to the batters, Astros players would watch the TV, and when they saw a fastball coming they did nothing. Any other pitch, they would hit a bat against a plastic garbage can. It sounded like this. Here it is again.
它是高科技工具和低成本恶作剧的结合。太空人队有一个摄像头直接对准对方球队的捕手，它将画面直播到休息区后面的通道里的电视上。为了将球路传达给击球手，太空人队的球员会看电视，当他们看到直球来临时，他们什么也不做。任何其他球，他们就会用球棒击打塑料垃圾桶。听起来像这样。再听一遍。
We tried to come up with an analogy for what it sounds like, but really, it sounds exactly like a bat hitting a plastic garbage can. Major League Baseball opened a full investigation into the accusations. The Astros manager and general manager were suspended and then fired by the team. The team was fined $5 million, which is not a lot of money for a franchise worth nearly $2 billion. The investigation confirmed the Astros had been signed stealing during the 2017 and 2018 seasons, and during the playoffs. And maybe even the World Series.
我们试图想出一个类比来形容它听起来像什么，但实际上，它听起来完全就像是一根球棒击打塑料垃圾桶的声音。美国职业棒球大联盟对这些指控展开了全面调查。太空人队的经理和总经理被停职，随后被球队解雇。该队被罚款500万美元，对于一个价值近20亿美元的特许经营球队来说，这并不是一笔巨款。调查证实，太空人队在2017年和2018赛季以及季后赛期间一直在偷暗号。甚至可能还有世界大赛。
The Astros are still the 2017 World Series champions, even though many baseball fans insist they deserve a massive asterisk. still the 2017 World Series champions, even though many baseball fans insist they deserve a massive asterisk. Some of the games biggest stars think that too, like Aaron Judge of the Yankees. And Mike Trout, the best player in baseball. It's sad for baseball. It's tough. They cheated.
太空人队仍然是2017年世界大赛冠军，尽管许多棒球迷坚称他们应该带上一个巨大的星号。仍然是2017年世界大赛冠军，尽管许多棒球迷坚称他们应该带上一个巨大的星号。一些棒球界的超级巨星也这么认为，比如扬基队的亚伦·贾奇。还有迈克·特劳特，棒球界最好的球员。这令人为棒球感到悲哀。这很艰难。他们作弊了。
I don't agree with the punishment. The Astros scandals created many what-ifs that can never be answered. No one denies that the Astros were a really talented team. But would they still be World Series champions if they hadn't cheated? Data analysts have tried to answer that question, and several prominent ones have found the advantage the Astros got from sign stealing might have been surprisingly small. Of course, a small advantage can mean a lot in such a competitive sport. These questions aren't so abstract for someone like Mike Bolsinger. An analysis by a computer
我不同意这种惩罚。太空人队的丑闻制造了许多永远无法回答的“如果”。没有人否认太空人队是一支极具天赋的球队。但如果他们没有作弊，他们还会是世界大赛冠军吗？数据分析师试图回答这个问题，几位著名的分析师发现，太空人队从偷暗号中获得的优势可能小得惊人。当然，在竞争如此激烈的运动中，微小的优势可能意味重大。对于像迈克·鲍尔辛格这样的人来说，这些问题并不是那么抽象。一位计算机程序员的分析
programmer revealed that when the Astros face Bolsinger They banged on their trash can lid 54 times the most times the Astros had used that system in all of 2017 And a lot of those bangs happened during bolsinger short appearance in the game Someone hit the trash can immediately before 12 of his 29 pitches It just makes you mad it thinks you, what would happen if I hadn't a pitch like that game? So then you start to question things about your career now. And then it truly was the most embarrassing moment
显示，当太空人队面对鲍尔辛格时，他们在垃圾桶盖上敲击了54次，这是太空人队在整个2017年使用该系统次数最多的一次。而且其中许多敲击发生在鲍尔辛格在比赛中短暂登场期间。有人在他的29次投球中的12次之前立即敲击了垃圾桶。这只会让你生气，让你想，如果我那场比赛没有那样投会发生什么？所以你会开始质疑你现在职业生涯中的事情。然后这确实是我职业生涯中
in my career. 100%. I've never been more embarrassed myself ever. Mike Boltsinger filed a legal complaint against the Astros on February 10, 2020. In the complaint, he blamed them for effectively cheating him out of his career. He's seeking damages. And he wants the team to give up $31 million in bonuses that the players received for
最尴尬的时刻。100%。我从来没有像那样感到更尴尬过。迈克·鲍尔辛格于2020年2月10日对太空人队提起法律诉讼。在诉状中，他指责他们实际上是通过作弊剥夺了他的职业生涯。他正在寻求损害赔偿。并且他要求球队交出球员们因赢得世界大赛而获得的3100万美元奖金，这些奖金将被捐赠给慈善事业。
winning the World Series, which would be donated to charity. It makes you matter once in a while. It truly does because you put so much work into getting to this spot in your career. And then you kind of find out, hey, this was taken away by people that cheated. This isn't exactly the first time somebody's broken the rules of baseball. In the early 2000s, there was the steroid scandal, and since the beginning of baseball, players have doctored the ball or put cork in their wooden bats or slid into their opponent's legs, cleats up.
偶尔会让你生气。确实如此，因为你为达到职业生涯的这个阶段付出了这么多的努力。然后你突然发现，嘿，这是被作弊的人夺走的。这绝对不是第一次有人打破棒球规则。2000年代初，有类固醇丑闻，而且自棒球创立以来，球员们就一直在对球做手脚，或者在他们的木棒里塞软木，或者用钉鞋高高抬起滑向对手的腿。
They say baseball is a game of inches, a game in which every small advantage matters, and the Astros embraced every edge they could find as they transformed themselves from a laughing stock into a champion. But when it came to baseball's age-old tradition of sign stealing, the Astros didn't just push to the edge, but over it. This episode is adapted from the edge, a six-part series hosted by Ben Rider.
他们说棒球是一项英寸必争的游戏，是一项每个微小优势都至关重要的游戏，而太空人队抓住了他们能找到的每一个优势，将自己从一个笑柄转变为一个冠军。但当谈到棒球那古老的偷暗号传统时，太空人队不仅推向了边缘，而且越过了边缘。本集改编自本·赖德主持的六集系列节目《边缘》。
You can download it now wherever you get your podcasts. What more would Ben? After this. So I'm back again with Ben Rider, and as we're talking this week, the Amy Coney Barrett hearings are happening in Washington and during the hearings, the Senator Ben Sass started attacking the Astros for seemingly no reason. So here's a clip of that. I'd like to talk about the Houston Astros who are miserable cheaters.
你现在可以在任何获取播客的地方下载它。本还有什么要说的？稍后继续。所以我又和本·赖德回来了，在我们这周的谈话中，艾米·科尼·巴雷特的听证会在华盛顿举行，在听证会期间，参议员本·萨斯开始无缘无故地攻击太空人队。所以这里是其中的一小段剪辑。我想谈谈休斯顿太空人队，他们是一群可悲的作弊者。
Sorry, Cornyn and Cruz, but both of the Texas senators said on this committee, but I think all baseball fans know that the Houston Astros cheat. They steal signs, they bang on cans. They've done a whole bunch of miserable things historically, and they deserve to be punished probably more than they have been. And then Ted Cruz, like defended the Astros and it feels really weird this is happening during a Supreme Court hearing. What did you make of all this? What I made of it, Roman, was that the Astros are now the go-to symbol for villainy for everybody, right? No matter who you are, no matter what you think, you can point at what the Astros did as representative of villainy,
抱歉，科宁和克鲁兹，但是德克萨斯州的两位参议员都在这个委员会里，但我认为所有的棒球迷都知道休斯顿太空人队作弊。他们偷暗号，他们敲击罐子。他们历史上做了一大堆可悲的事情，他们理应受到惩罚，可能比他们已经受到的惩罚还要多。然后泰德·克鲁兹，好像为太空人队进行了辩护，感觉这件事发生在最高法院听证会期间真的很奇怪。你对这一切有何看法？我的看法是，罗曼，太空人队现在成了每个人眼中十恶不赦的代名词，对吧？不管你是谁，不管你怎么想，你都可以指出太空人队所做的事情代表了邪恶，
as representative of corruption, and there's little risk in doing it. That's what I took away from that. Right, right. So you mentioned on the show that you've covered the Astros and you wrote about them for Sports Illustrated and you actually wrote a whole book called Astro Ball.
代表了腐败，而且这样做几乎没有什么风险。这就是我从中所得到的。对，对。所以你在节目中提到你曾报道过太空人队，你为《体育画报》写过关于他们的文章，你甚至还写了一整本名为《太空人球》的书。
So when you heard about the sign stealing, what did you think? Were you personally disappointed? I was really, really surprised because I had spent so much time with this team over the years I'd written a whole book about them, as you said, and I had no idea about this. But I was also interested in part of my own reaction,
所以当你听到偷暗号的事情时，你是怎么想的？你个人感到失望吗？我真的，真的很惊讶，因为这些年来我花了很多时间和这支球队在一起，正如你所说，我写了一整本关于他们的书，而我对这个一无所知。但我也对我自己的部分反应很感兴趣，
which is that while I was surprised by the particulars, I wasn't entirely shocked to hear that the Astros had been the one to do this, just because they did everything to an extreme, right? Their pursuit of the edge went so far in every way, most of them perfectly legal, that it kind of made sense that, oh, maybe they just took sign stealing, which as we know from the episode is an age-old tradition, and baseball to a new extreme as well. So that was kind of what sent me on my quest here and sent me into the making of my podcast to answer that. And many other questions about a subject I thought I knew really well. So we talk about this long history of sign stealing in various ways in which, you know, people did it and it was really egregious and violated
那就是虽然我对细节感到惊讶，但我并不完全对太空人队是做出这种事的那支球队感到震惊，只是因为他们把一切都做到了极致，对吧？他们对优势的追求在各个方面都走得太远了，其中大部分完全是合法的，所以这就说得通了，哦，也许他们只是把偷暗号（正如我们从节目中知道的那样，这是棒球界一项古老的传统）也带到了一个新的极端。所以这可以说是促使我在这里进行探索，并促使我制作我的播客来回答这个问题。以及关于一个我以为自己非常了解的主题的许多其他问题。所以我们以各种方式讨论了偷暗号这段悠久的历史，你知道，人们这样做而且非常恶劣并违反了规范，也有一些不那么恶劣、人们觉得还可以的方式。太空人队在这一切中处于什么位置？嗯，正如我们所听到的，棒球界每个人都在作弊。
norms in ways in which it was not so egregious and people kind of thought it was okay. Where did the Astros fit into all this? Well, as we heard, everybody cheats in baseball. But it's kind of like everybody else is going 75 in a 65 mile an hour zone, right? And the Astros went straight to 100. And what they did also fit into their kind of technocratic MO, which the baseball world had really started to turn against. This was an age-old, fun, admired tradition. And they took all the fun and artistry out of it, right? It almost used to be like a paper film.
但这有点像在限速65英里的区域里，其他人都在以75英里的时速行驶，对吧？而太空人队直接飙到了100英里。而且他们所做的事情也符合他们那种技术官僚的作风，棒球界其实已经开始对此产生反感。这是一项古老、有趣、受人尊敬的传统。而他们把所有的乐趣和艺术性都从其中抽离了，对吧？它过去几乎就像是一部纸质电影。
The telescopes here, the binoculars here. What the Astros did was this kind of like mechanized dominance and it rubbed a lot of people the wrong way. So one of the big questions that we ask in this episode and is part of like mechanized dominance and erode a lot of people the wrong way. So one of the big questions that we ask in this episode is part of the series is would the Astros be World Series champions without sign stealing. They made the playoffs this year. They did not make it to the World Series.
望远镜在这里，双筒望远镜在这里。太空人队所做的是这种机械化的统治，这让很多人感到不舒服。所以在这一集以及系列节目中，我们提出的重大问题之一就是：没有偷暗号，太空人队还会是世界大赛冠军吗？他们今年打进了季后赛。他们没有进入世界大赛。
Out of the right of second in the pitch, swing it off, pop fly shallow right, charging Margot he is under it. And the Tampa Bay rays have just won the American League Pemet for the second time in franchise history, the rays are on their way to the world, Siri. Does that kind of settle the question? I mean, what do you think? No, I don't think it settles the question. And that's one of the tragedies of this entire story is that we'll never be able to go back and replay that history fair. And why did a team that was already so talented feel like they had to do this. They were so good anyway, right? We met Mike Bulsinger in our episode just now.
球飞向右外野，挥棒落空，浅右外野飞球，玛戈冲过去，他在球的正下方。坦帕湾光芒队刚刚赢得了特许经营史上的第二个美联锦标赛，光芒队正在前往世界大赛的路上。这是否算是解决了这个问题？我的意思是，你怎么看？不，我不认为这解决了问题。这就是整个故事的悲剧之一，我们将永远无法回去公平地重播那段历史。为什么一支已经如此有才华的球队会觉得他们必须这样做呢？他们本来就已经很优秀了，对吧？我们在刚刚的节目中遇到了迈克·鲍尔辛格。
A guy who throws 90 miles an hour whose ERA is near five in his career, which isn't so great. A team like the Astros could have knocked him around. They could have ended his career anyway fairly, but it wasn't fair. So one of the things I really want to know is why did a team with all this talent take this extra step? It didn't even necessarily need. It kind of reminds me of the Watergate break-in. Nixon was so far ahead,
一个球速90英里、职业生涯防御率接近5的投手，这其实不算太好。像太空人队这样的球队本可以把他打得落花流水。他们本可以以公正的方式无论如何结束他的职业生涯，但那是不公平的。所以我想知道的事情之一是，为什么一支拥有如此多天赋的球队要采取这额外的一步？这甚至不一定是必需的。这有点让我想起水门事件的窃听。尼克松当时领先那么多，
but they still had to break into the DNC to make himself feel better about to make him more comfortable with winning. I had to cheat to win, even though it was winning. It's sort of a weird tragedy to have people like that, you know. You know, I made this podcast with Prologue projects, including the guys who made the Watergate season of Slowburn. They're not big sports people, but they certainly know about scandals like this. And I think it was that element that really connected with
但他们仍然不得不闯入民主党全国委员会，让自己对赢得比赛感觉更好，让自己对胜利感到更安心。我不得不作弊才能赢，尽管当时他已经在赢了。让这样的人存在，这简直是一种奇怪的悲剧，你知道的。你知道，我与Prologue Projects合作制作了这个播客，其中包括制作《Slowburn》水门事件季的人。他们不是狂热的体育迷，但他们绝对了解像这样的丑闻。我想正是那个元素真正与他们产生了共鸣并延续至今。
them and continues to. So we're only covering one small aspect of the entire series that you're doing called the edge. What can people expect when they subscribe to this? They're going to rush out and subscribe right now to the edge. What are they going to hear? There's a lot more to this. You learn a lot more about why they did it, exactly who was doing it. The specific dynamics within the organization that led to corruption like this taking root.
所以我们只报道了你正在做的名为《边缘》的整个系列节目中的一小部分。当人们订阅这个节目时，他们可以期待什么？他们会赶快去订阅《边缘》。他们会听到什么？这里面还有很多内容。你会了解到更多关于他们为什么要这样做，到底是谁在做这件事。导致这种腐败扎根的组织内部的具体动态。
Now I'm gonna give you a little teaser. You also learned something else that they were running a second sign stealing system parallel to the first at the same time. But you're gonna have to subscribe to the edge to find out about that. I'm not giving that away right now. Oh, I love it. I love it.
现在我要给你们一个小预告。你们还将了解到另一件事，他们同时还在运行第二个与第一个平行的偷暗号系统。但你们得去订阅《边缘》才能了解那件事。我现在可不会剧透。哦，我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。
That's fantastic. Well, that's so cool. It's called the Edge. Ben Ryder is our reporter and was the host of the whole series. Thank you so much for doing this story with us. It was a lot of fun. So much fun, Roman.
这太棒了。嗯，这太酷了。它叫《边缘》。本·赖德是我们的记者，也是整个系列节目的主持人。非常感谢你和我们一起做这个故事。这太有趣了。非常有趣，罗曼。
Thanks a lot. This week's episode was adapted from The Edge, which is produced by Prologg Projects in partnership with Cadence 13. The show is made by Ben Rider and Sam Lee. The team at Prologg Projects includes Leon Nayfok and Andrew Parsons. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Chris Barubay, music by Sean Riel, soundmits by Kevin Ransom, like checking by Francis Caw. Our senior producer is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Leigh, Christopher Johnson, Abby McDonald, Katie Mingle, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars.
非常感谢。本周的节目改编自《边缘》，该节目由 Prologue Projects 与 Cadence 13 合作制作。该节目由本·赖德和萨姆·李制作。Prologue Projects 的团队包括莱昂·奈福克和安德鲁·帕森斯。99% Invisible 本周由克里斯·巴鲁贝制作，肖恩·里尔配乐，凯文·兰姆森负责音效剪辑，弗朗西斯·考负责事实核查。我们的高级制作人是德兰尼·霍尔，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德、乔·罗森伯格、薇薇安·李、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、艾比·麦克唐纳、凯蒂·明格、索菲亚·克拉茨克和我罗曼·马尔斯。
We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, which has scattered across the North American continent, but the geographic center, the exact mathematical geographic center, is centered right there, lands right there, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a founding member of Radio Topia from BRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative Lister supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world. Find them all at radiotopia.evm. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org on Instagram and write it too.
我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于 Radio Row，该广播站散布在北美大陆，但其地理中心，确切的数学地理中心，就位于美丽繁华的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是 BRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的创始成员，这是一个充满激情的独立集体，由世界上最具创新性、由听众支持、100% 艺术家拥有的播客组成。请在 radiotopia.fm 上找到它们。你可以在 Instagram 上发推文给我 @Roman Mars，也可以发给节目 @99PI org。
But you can get the brand new New York Times best-selling book 99% InvisibleCity at 99PI.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你可以在 99PI.org 上买到全新的《纽约时报》畅销书《99% Invisible City》。Radio Topia。来自 PRX。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。